j'ai à tous et bonjour cher françois
parce qu'effectivement j'ai le grand
plaisir de prendre ton rôle et je me
trouve
à l'hôtel matignon où depuis hier matin
jeu sert de guide à nos concitoyens pour
les journées du patrimoine
ils viennent voir ce magnifique lieu et
je dois vous dire que je me régale avec
toutes ces françaises et tous les
français de toutes conditions qui
viennent ici pour ce moment exceptionnel
en m'adressant à vous toutes et à vous
tous chers amis je m'adresse à un parti
de la majorité présidentielle parti j'ai
le sait qui est un allié essentiel du
président de la république et de la
république en
non seulement je dirais que vous êtes un
des piliers de cette majorité mais une
famille politique
y est
ancien de ce pays tue
il doit notamment
des valeurs tout à fait moderne un
engagement européen sans faille
la conception même de la
décentralisation
peut-être par dessus tout dirais-je le
fait d'avoir toujours mis la personne
humaine au coeur du débat de société à
des époques
où l'on pensait peut-être davantage
d'optimisme
ou le développement a été perçu comme
une fin en soi et où le coût humain
social et environnemental n'entraîne pas
nécessairement en tout cas pas
suffisamment en compte dans les
arbitrages et les décisions bruit
derrière votre famille politique
hier votre parti il ya bien sûr des
femmes des hommes
une histoire des combats mais surtout
une pensée
politique la france en a besoin
allez dire le président de la république
en a besoin ja même voie
en effet dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre
bon bah nous adresser aux
français sans que notre discours soit
construit sur un socle solide
sur un sens profond
sur une passe et politiques de l'ong
certes
force la majorité
et la majorité parlementaire notamment
que je dirige a d'autres l'inspiration
et d'autres inspirateur que les seuls
défenseurs de la démocratie et y est
mais je ne l'imaginé pas sans cette part
de notre histoire politique commune
cette part
besoin de le souligner devant vous en
soit françois bayrou la porte
elle incarne avec je dirais la même
détermination et la même constance
1 qu'il a toujours montré pour défendre
l'indépendance et l'identité de votre
famille
si l'engagement
de françois a pu aussi porté ses fruits
c'est bien sûr grâce à vous toutes et
vous tous élus militants
mais aussi je veux le souligner à ce
stade de mon propos grâce au soutien
sans faille de marienne aliens de sarnez
qui se bat aujourd'hui entre la maladie
avec la force et le courage que nous lui
connaissons
à bientôt
karma et elle a très vite et je n'oublie
pas davantage
cher patrick le rôle déterminant du
groupe parlementaire modèle
j'ai plaisir à entretenir je le crois
des relations de grande confiance et
d'amitié
[Musique]
je veux répéter devant vous
combien je me réjouis de la recréation
pour laquelle je milite de longue date
d'un haut commissariat au plan
et au fait que la charge anne et été
confiée à françois bayrou
cette fonction
voulu par le général de gaulle
a permis à notre pays non seulement de
se relever des désastres la guerre mais
d'entamer une des plus formidables
période de modernisation et de
croissance là
françois a donc aujourd'hui la lourde
tâche de nous aider à dessiner pour le
pays
les chemins de demain
de faire entrer dans le débat public
les questions la conscience des risques
et des chances
que l'évolution des temps offre à notre
société et à l'état
les idées de votre ami politique
et rig
à pensée réformatrice ce pays depuis des
décennies
en plaçant françois bayrou à la tête du
haut commissariat au plan
le président de la république emmanuel
moi et moi même
sauf convaincu qu'elles continueront à
nourrir
l'effort de transformation
initiée après la victoire de 2010 cette
victoire à laquelle vous avez tant
contribué
qui est également au coeur du plan de
relance que nous engageons
il lui revient en somme de projeter la
france de 2003
plus généralement les chers amis je sais
pouvoir compter sur vous sur le modem
pour porter le message des territoires
le message de la france des villes et
des lilas
le message du bon sens
ce dont nous avons tant besoin dans les
circonstances et 5
elles font partie je le sais de votre
histoire de votre expérience j'allais
presque dire de votre adn
c'est en effet vous en êtes comme quoi
convaincu au coeur des territoires dans
chacune de ces petites communes où l'on
a laissé se défaire le maillage social
pendant de trop nombreuses années
ces zones industrielles des membres et
par la mondialisation
dans ses campagnes
souvent méprisé et parfois abandonnées
que nous allons ensemble porter l'action
vu gouvernement nous devons vous le
savez
c'est à trois crises
même temps
akriche sanitaires
hélas s
adieu la crise économique et sociale
avec tous ces drames la crise d'autorité
qui mine notre pacte républicain
le moment est grave
il est donc propice à tous les sursauts
nous n'y parviendrons mes chers amis
dans le sens tracé par emmanuel macron
depuis 2017
nous ne parviendrons que par la
conviction
à l'offensive
sion de la confiance
unité
et par le rassemblement
dans cette voie
c'est pouvoir parfaitement confiait
compter sur le modem sur toutes les
femmes et les hommes
il participe de ce grand parti de ce
grand mouvement et par avance je vous en
remercie